in early 1848 a humble Carpenter was
working on a water-powered lumber mill
in what was soon to become California or
Pioneer John Sutter when he saw it a
nugget of solid gold and within a matter
of months stories of gold in Sutter's
Creek had spread like herpes in a mining
camp fast forward a few months and three
quarters of San Francisco's male
population had left for the gold mines
just four years later Sutter was
bankrupt his farm had been invaded by
prospectus and all his livestock was
stolen Sam Brannan on the other hand was
soon to become California's first
millionaire Brannan had invested in
mining equipment and was selling it at
exorbitant prices